[Música]
Hola bienvenidos esto es una semana en
el mundo el programa de France 24 en el
que con nuestros periodistas invitados
conversamos sobre algunos de los hechos
más destacados de la semana Este
programa es el espacio para que los
periodistas expresen su opinión Comenten
sus puntos de vista sobre los temas de
la actualidad mundial para conversar
justamente sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para esta semana hemos
invitado a Paula Andrea Suárez ella es
editor internacional de Caracol radio en
Colombia nos acompaña aquí en el estudio
de France 24 Paula Andrea bienvenida y
cuéntenos cómo termina su semana
Santiago Muchas gracias por la
invitación y esta semana termina
emocionante comienza el mundial y pienso
que eso ha sido lo que ha unido también
al mundo en medio de tanta atención pero
también ha sido un panorama en el que el
mundial se ha prestado mucho para la
controversia política que también está
sucediendo en el mundo y bueno y también
reanudación de diálogos que creo que eso
ha sido también lo que ha movido no solo
no solo al país sino también pues la
frontera con Venezuela que ha sido tan
tan agitado en los últimos tiempos tema
importante para Colombia y para
Venezuela lo vamos a tratar en esta
edición del programa también está con
nosotros Rafael niño él es periodista de
citynoticias del Canal City TV un canal
local de la ciudad de Bogotá en Colombia
Rafael también bienvenido también Usted
trabaja allí los temas internacionales
en citynoticias cuéntenos como termina
la semana Santiago Muchísimas gracias
por la invitación a Paula a Pablo que
nos acompaña más adelante lo vamos a
conocer una semana Ya lo decía Paula
emocionante pero también contradictoria
una semana en la que tuvimos tiroteos
noticias tristes Como siempre todo se
mueve entonces las emociones Nos tienen
ahí jalando por un lado el mundial por
un lado lo que está pasando lamentable
en el mundo protestas entonces hay
muchas cosas que por supuesto las
abordaremos acá y estamos felices de
estar acá Bueno pues a los dos qué
periodistas que me acompañan en el
estudio Gracias por estar con nosotros
en esta oportunidad y desde la ciudad de
Washington en Estados Unidos se conecta
Pablo pardo él es corresponsal del
diario el mundo para Estados Unidos
Pablo bienvenido también al programa y
cuéntenos cómo termina usted la semana
allí en la capital de Estados Unidos
Hola qué tal Muchas gracias por traerme
aquí en vuestro programa bueno esta
semana es un poco extraña en Estados
Unidos porque es la semana de Thanks
digamos que esto viene a ser
prácticamente como Navidad o Nochebuena
en otros muchos países de Europa de
América Latina todo absolutamente todo
se detiene y bueno la actividad de todo
tipo se paraliza con la única excepción
de los tweets de elon musk que se ha
convertido en El reemplazo de Donald
Trump a la hora de volver loca a esa red
social y luego si evidentemente tenemos
los las cosas desgraciadamente que pasan
siempre en Estados Unidos
matanzas hemos tenido una gran cantidad
de matanzas en los últimos 10 días y
bueno evidentemente el mundial de Qatar
la situación Ucrania que aquí siempre se
sigue muy de cerca con mucho debate
dentro de la Pero bueno es un fin de
semana bastante único en el año un fin
de semana único Pablo Pero rescató ese
fin de semana la reactivación que
representa este día para la economía de
Estados Unidos para la industria
aeronáutica la cantidad de personas que
se mueven en los diferentes vuelos en
los diferentes medios de transporte le
viene bien a la economía de Estados
Unidos por lo menos este fin de semana
pero bueno ustedes también nos pueden
acompañar con sus opiniones y todos sus
comentarios pueden dejar las preguntas a
través de las redes sociales ya las
conocen arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral una semana en el mundo pues
comenzamos entramos en materia y
comenzamos en nuestra región porque aquí
en América Latina están avanzando dos
mesas de diálogo que están generando
muchísima expectativa no solo en América
Latina sino también en el mundo entero
la primera es el inicio de esas
conversaciones entre el gobierno
colombiano con representantes de la
guerrilla del eln una negociación que
hace parte de llamada Paz Total que es
una propuesta del presidente colombiano
Gustavo Petro Asimismo el gobierno de
Nicolás maduro y la oposición están
preparándose para instaurar una mesa de
diálogo retomar esas conversaciones en
México que tiene como principal marco
pues establecer las reglas para las
elecciones presidenciales en Venezuela
en el 2024 maduro está muy deseoso de
mantener esa nueva visibilidad que tiene
a nivel internacional que ha ganado
recientemente y también la oposición
necesita unificarse que tal vez la gran
deuda pendiente que tiene la oposición
en Venezuela y nos preguntamos entonces
pues cómo va a estar organizada ese
marco para los comicios presidenciales
en Venezuela comienzo entonces con Pablo
Andrea aquí en el estudio de France 24
Comencemos por los diálogos en Colombia
muchísima expectativa como se han
desarrollado a lo largo de esta semana
que dicen en Colombia los medios de
comunicación Y cómo han tomado esta
iniciación de los diálogos bueno
Santiago Yo pienso que ha sido una
semana trascendental trascendental para
el porque tengamos en cuenta en cuenta
que se están reanudando diálogos que
venían pausados desde el gobierno de
Juan Manuel Santos y que ahorita en
estos momentos
el hecho de poder otra vez retomar y que
fuera El Punto de partida del gobierno
de Gustavo Petro pues ha sido como un
aliciente también no solo para Colombia
sino también a nivel mundial de hecho
ayer estaba analizando el tema del
secretario general de la ONU de Antonio
Gutiérrez que él manifestó y dijo Es una
inspiración para Colombia el hecho de
que se esté llevando a cabo este proceso
de paz que venía pausado obviamente
desde hace varios años pero también
resaltaba bastante el apoyo de parte de
Naciones Unidas para el país y yo pienso
que el hecho de poder tener ese apoyo de
desde las organizaciones internacionales
que antes de pronto nos estaba viendo
porque no había
como como un proceso de paz delimitado
marcado como una línea de de de
conducción Pues eso había hecho que es
que se viera como truncado el tema de
los diálogos de paz Pero ahorita lo veo
como algo visible los medios lo han
visto como algo muy positivo y acá no se
trata de tomar partido de o si te gusta
Petro si no te gusta sino de que por fin
de pronto puede llegar la paz para el
país después rápidamente usted está
dedicada a la información internacional
Rafael también pero esto acaparado la
agenda de las redacciones en Colombia en
los medios colombianos Claro que sí de
hecho en medio de Pues de todo el tema
que tenemos con el mundial que ha sido
lo que ha paralizado creo que la
programación de la mayoría de medios se
le ha dado mucha prioridad a este tema
claro y justamente pues se unieron ambos
ambas cosas entonces Claro que sí Rafael
ya le doy la palabra cruzo hasta
Washington para conocer la opinión de
Pablo sobre el inicio de esta mesa de
diálogo Colombia y la guerrilla del Ln
su opinión que análisis hace usted al
respecto
Bueno lo primero de todo no sois
Vosotros los que sabéis de esto porque
estáis sobre el terreno pero aquí en
Estados Unidos Esta es una negociación
que se observa con mucho digamos
optimismo y con mucho apoyo es decir la
idea de
Colombia pues termine prácticamente Pues
no sé cuánto puede ser 50-60 años de
violencia política es algo muy
importante y el gobierno de Joe biden
apoya esta iniciativa hay más cuestiones
también en el aire Es decir porque el Ln
recibe apoyo de Venezuela de hecho yo
creo que así watch prácticamente lo ha
considerado prácticamente como un
instrumento de la política exterior
venezolana lo cual también supone
parte pienso yo de
acercamiento entre Estados Unidos y sus
aliados y al vosotros aliados no
solamente me refiero a sus aliados en
América Latina también en Europa y el
gobierno
venezolano lo cual también a su vez está
relacionado con las negociaciones entre
el gobierno de maduro y la oposición
venezolana con lo cual digamos que abre
Abre una fase extremadamente interesante
y que puede tener consecuencias muy
favorables queda una cuestión pienso yo
y que aquí en Washington también
preocupa digamos es si verdaderamente se
va a llevar a cabo una desmovilización
completa en el caso de que yo me acuerdo
de paz o se puede haber elementos del Ln
Pues que como sucedió con los FARC y
precisamente esta semana creo que ha
habido un incidente que ha muerto unas
20 personas
que han integrado
en otras actividades
y pasó a darle la palabra a Rafael para
terminar esta primera ronda sobre este
tema de las negociaciones con el Ln su
opinión pues Santiago a propósito del
tema de Estados Unidos esta tarde la
mesa emitió el segundo comunicado de los
resultados y en ellos no solo ratifican
Cuáles van a ser los países garantes
acompañantes sino que dejan al final le
hemos comunicado a Estados Unidos su
decisión si quiere o no participar de
esto O sea no solo como lo no lo contaba
Pablo de que lo apoyen de que lo vean
desde afuera sino los están llamando y
los están sentando a la mesa y creo que
es el punto que se debe destacar de
estas de estas conversaciones Y es que
lo han hecho de forma de rigurosa Sí
nosotros está sentando la izquierda por
primera vez en el poder y a decirle
venga ustedes la izquierda también se
puede puede llegar al poder y no por la
violencia venga y hagámoslo y también
cogidos en toda la derecha y le dice
aquí ponemos a los ganaderos Aquí van a
participar para evitar que errores que
se cometieron en Colombia como el
plebiscito que se dejó no se escuchó un
lado y al final pues conocemos los
entonces siento que lo han hecho bien es
un mensaje muy poderoso que estén
integrados todos y es el reto este
gobierno lo que ha promovido y lo que se
vendió como se vendió Y cómo llegó ahí
era precisamente era esto integrar a
todos para poder buscar una solución
entonces creo que también hay un poco de
esperanza de que se pueda hacer bien
esta vez es la séptima vez que se van a
sentar con un gobierno en Colombia
lln es la primera vez que lo van a hacer
con un gobierno de izquierda Entonces
vamos a ver cómo funciona esta vez y
pues claramente Todos queremos que
funcione que se acabe la violencia hay
gente en los territorios que está
sufriendo problemas con el orden público
que está siendo hostigada que tiene
dificultades para vivir y ese es otro
punto del comunicado dice hay que hacer
acciones humanitarias urgentes para
solucionarle el problema a la gente en
los territorios que finalmente lo que se
quiere para eso es que están sentando
allá a hablar garantizar la seguridad en
la zona Rurales que sigue siendo la
deuda pendiente del gobierno colombiano
a hacer presencia garantizar presencia
allí en Pablo yo retomo algo de lo que
dice Rafael y es esta parte del
comunicado donde se invita a Estados
Unidos O sea que tal esté un poco más
allá que simplemente un espectador de la
comunidad internacional viendo estas
negociaciones y tal vez se anima a tomar
un papel más activo puede Estados Unidos
de pronto tomar un papel más activo esto
le convendría de pronto para hacer un
poco de engranaje esto de Cara a esas
negociaciones que también están
avanzando o que van a comenzar entre el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición que le interesa mucho al
gobierno de Estados Unidos por el tema
petrolero obviamente
Bueno evidentemente yo no sé lo que
piensa o cuál es la posición del
gobierno de Estados Unidos pero desde
luego el gobierno de Estados Unidos sí
que apoya firmemente estas negociaciones
Y sí que está al menos indirectamente e
informalmente involucrado hay que tener
en cuenta también cuestiones de índole
política interna muchas cosas de la
política exterior de Estados Unidos en
realidad se definen en términos de
política interna la cuestión todo lo que
tenga que ver con Venezuela y con
América Latina en Estados Unidos tiene
se resumen una palabra Florida y Florida
ahora mismo es un estado Que es
completamente republicano con lo cual el
gobierno de Joe biden digamos que no
tiene mucho que perder si se rompe con
con esquemas tradicionales de la
política de Estados Unidos si lleva a
cabo un acercamiento más grande hacia el
gobierno de maduro etcétera Por lo cual
Esta es una de las cuestiones y la otra
evidentemente es lo que comentabas del
petróleo esto juega un papel fundamental
y cuarto había un papel mucho más
importante en el año 2023 bueno va a
empezar a jugarlo dentro de 8 días
cuando entré en vigor el tope al precio
del petróleo que los países del g7 del
petróleo ruso que los países del g7 van
a pagar pero en 2023 todo lo que tenga
que ver con petróleo y con energía va a
ser todavía mucho más importante Y por
consiguiente todo lo que tenga que ver
con Venezuela claro Hay mucha
expectativa en torno a lo que pueda
pasar en esta mesa de negociación es la
primera semana de conversaciones es el
establecimiento de la mesa hay hay
muchísima expectativa en torno a las
discusiones pero también hay mucha
expectativa y también creo que en todas
las redacciones nos toma un poco por
sorpresa el anuncio hecho por parte del
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
luego lo confirmaron desde Caracas que
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición se sientan nuevamente a
dialogar en México este fin de semana
hay muchísima expectativa sobre este
tema pero también
viendo las dinámicas las mesas de
conversación anteriores vemos que hay
falta de compromiso de algunas de las
partes la oposición se levanta del
gobierno no se compromete siempre estás
Te rifirrafe entre las partes qué
esperamos ahora qué podemos ver de estas
de esta mesa de negociación para la
Andrea Yo pienso que es un paso positivo
a propósito Pues de los diálogos que se
están reanudando con lln porque
finalmente también es algo que que lleva
dividiendo a Venezuela por muchos años y
donde ya se necesita que haya por lo
menos un acuerdo o algún tipo de amistad
así no sea tan estrecha por parte de la
oposición y el gobierno venezolano
Porque si bien
lleva tantos años tantos años de tanto
rechazo por parte digamos de la
oposición hacia el gobierno si llega a
ver una Unión eso sería también un
ejemplo no sólo a la región del cono Sur
sino también a nivel mundial si llega a
ver de pronto Alguna algún nuevo acuerdo
o que o que esto pueda facilitar la
economía en el país y bueno Y también
por el tema de favorita propósito de lo
que comentaba Pablo con el tema de la
reactivación también tener en cuenta que
que Chevron está nuevamente instalando
partes de su negocio petrolero pues ya
en el país y eso pues es una aliciente
también para Venezuela que ha llevado
por tanto tiempo esta crisis económica
tan fuerte Entonces pienso que muy
positivo yo no suelo dar opiniones en
los programas pero yo soy bastante
escéptico frente a esta mesa de diálogo
porque creo que también hace parte como
esa estrategia de visibilidad
internacional que está teniendo Nicolás
Maduro que piensa usted Rafael hace
parte como de este impulso que está
teniendo mostrándose otra vez muy
abierto muy democrático aquí oyendo
todas las partes pero a la hora de la
verdad y ni tanto Santiago Mira esta
mañana y llegó un fuller en una
entrevista que le hicieron en radio
Miraflores y no estoy mal y él decía
aquí no se suspendieron las
negociaciones aquí nunca hemos dejado
hablar en Venezuela dice él Dice nos
vamos a sentar a hablar otra vez con esa
extrema que no logró su objetivo de
cumplir un golpe de estado entonces
entonces de una vez entra a chocar con
la posición entonces claro es muy
difícil pero esto también hace parte
como usted lo mencionaba de una
estrategia quien anuncia estas
negociaciones el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro es porque ahí está
mediando de hace parte de también Buscar
estabilidad en religión en la región hay
dos telones de fondo en esto muy
importante Ya lo mencionado en la crisis
en Ucrania del problema con el petróleo
necesitan hacer alianzas estrategias de
Estados Unidos desde el año pasado se
fue y se asentó allá y dijo venga
hablemos Sí entonces también no todo se
reduce alianzas relacionadas con los
derechos humanos con el tipo de régimen
sino ya estamos hablando a ver si nos
podemos dar pasito en el tema comercial
y el otro es el giro político que está
teniendo América Latina Cuántos
gobiernos de izquierda ya tenemos en
América Latina entonces a Estados Unidos
tampoco le conviene tener esas
desestabilidad en la región necesita
tener aliados Colombia siempre ha estado
ahí pero necesita empezar a atender
puentes más porque al otro lado está
teniendo problemas y no sabemos cuánto
podría prolongar eso y cómo vaya a
tomarse la situación allá entonces todo
es un juego de estrategias esperemos que
también les funcione porque
al igual que en la mesa de lln aquí
también la prioridad es solucionarle el
problema a la gente y ellos dicen Ahí
viene el comunicado necesitamos primero
que solucionar el tema de vacunas de
salud de infraestructura de escuelas es
lo que finalmente necesita Venezuela Más
allá de y dar el salto del tema político
y es como venga allá hay una situación
grave ya la doy la palabra Pablo por
aquí me pide la palabra para Andrea
únicamente respecto a lo que está
hablando Rafael el desbloqueo de los
2.700 millones de dólares qué sucedería
si llega a ver obviamente un
restablecimiento o un acuerdo entre la
oposición y el gobierno y y esto Pues
Más allá de pronto de una estrategia
ahorita como lo comentabas podría ser
algo que funcionaría bien porque
finalmente Sería para la construcción de
nuevas redes eléctricas y también para
proyectos de salud yo lo veo en ese lado
como algo favorable pero también ahorita
cuando lo mencionaste si estuve muy de
acuerdo porque es una de las críticas y
que de hecho Muchos medios también lo
han titulado de esa de ese lado y es que
es un hecho de volver otra vez a
posicionar a Venezuela no como una
dictadura sino ya como el gobierno que
está resurgiendo y que está en cabeza de
un presidente como Nicolás Maduro además
que hay un factor ahí muy importante y
es que hay elecciones presidenciales en
el 2024 y hay que ver cómo se van a
establecer Esas reglas del juego ya la
doy la palabra Rafael escuchemos a Pablo
en la ciudad de Washington que tiene
para decir sobre este tema Sí yo yo
estoy Completamente de acuerdo con Pablo
Andrea y con Rafael creo que la cuestión
fundamental es el gobierno venezolano
negocia desde una posición de
superioridad o de fortalezas Eso quiere
decir y la oposición negocia desde una
oposición de debilidad Y esto es
absolutamente En mi opinión esto esto
incuestionable por consiguiente si se
llega a un acuerdo las concesiones las
va a tener que hacer la oposición que ya
es la parte más débil que además ha
tenido siempre unos problemas de
organización unos problemas de Liderazgo
muy grandes y que ha perdido gran parte
de su respaldo internacional con lo cual
yo no sé muy bien A qué tipo de acuerdos
se puede llegar es decir yo no sé porque
casi lo que a priori casi lo que cabría
pensar es que se va a producir una
rendición con algunas condiciones de la
oposición lo cual es inaceptable para la
oposición pero el gobierno de maduro
digamos que es consciente de que ahora
mismo sea una posición de fortaleza y
que además el tiempo juega en su favor
aquí la pregunta que queda Entonces es
qué tanto margen de negociación tiene la
oposición tiene los recursos económicos
de Venezuela el acceso algunas cuentas
internacionales pero ya incluso
presidentes de otros países están
hablando directamente con maduro Juan
guaidó que es el representante de la
oposición está quedando en un limbo a
nivel internacional debo cerrar este
tema por acá finalmente estas
conversaciones apenas van a comenzar
este fin de semana en México ya veremos
Cómo se desarrollan y debo pasar a otro
tema importante a nivel internacional y
son justamente ese incremento de la
atención en Irán esta semana nuevamente
Vimos a manifestantes en diferentes
ciudades de la República islámica en las
calles protestando el descontento se
mantiene pero eso es manifestantes que
salieron primero a reclamar por la
muerte de Masha Andy que luego salieron
a reclamar por los derechos de las
mujeres y de las minorías ahora piden la
salida del régimen de los ayatolá y
piden un cambio en el rumbo de la
República islámica esta semana también
el consejo de los derechos humanos de la
ONU aprobó abrir una investigación
independiente sobre la represión de las
protestas a generan Teherán Consideró
que no es necesaria lo considero de
hecho una violación a su soberanía
también
reforzó la presencia estoy hablando del
gobierno iraní reforzó la presencia
militar en las regiones kurdas y en las
zonas de minoría baluch ante la
posibilidad del reconocimiento de las
manifestaciones lo vemos analiza en
France 24 comienzo con Pablo para hacer
la ronda la inversa
está el régimen en un punto de no
retorno está el gobierno de los ayatolá
en un en un cierre de un capítulo y está
Irán poco a poco tratando de construir
un nuevo capítulo en su historia o se
está derrumbando todo este este
andamiaje de la revolución islámica
Bueno yo creo que esa es la pregunta que
todos nos hacemos yo me lo iba a
responder Pablo
A mí me encantaría ser capaces de
responderla vamos y a continuación de
hacer algunos bets en el mercado del
petróleo
sacar algo de dinero es muy difícil
saberlo porque el régimen Es un régimen
muy cerrado la sociedad iraní es una
sociedad mucho más sofisticada y más
conectada con el exterior que la de
otros muchos países de la región siempre
lo ha sido con lo cual siempre ha habido
una una desconexión muy grande y en
estas protestas en este caso hay hay dos
factores que juegan un papel muy
importante uno que se están prolongando
en el tiempo mucho muchísimo más de lo
que cabía pensar en un primer momento el
segundo elemento es que ahora mismo
estamos parece que están empezando a
aparecer cuestiones
digamos
étnicas o regionales esto que comentabas
de tensión en las áreas que son más o
menos en el Noroeste del país y en las
áreas baluchis que es en la frontera con
Pakistán sobre todo y Afganistán
exactamente en el otro extremo del país
en el en el suroeste perdón el sureste
esto es un factor que a los ayatolás y
digamos a toda la república islámica
le tiene que preocupar mucho porque abre
la posibilidad de conflictos étnicos de
conflicto regionales que Irán son muy
reales y siempre han sido aplastados a
sangre y fuego y además pueden estallar
otros muchos hay una población árabes un
muy importante en el suroeste están los
aferíes etcétera con lo cual Este es un
problema muy importante Tenemos también
el papel de Estados Unidos en la última
oleada de protestas en la parte de la
primavera árabe que hubo en Irán Estados
Unidos explícitamente no apoyo a los
manifestantes en esta ocasión no sabemos
si lo está apoyando no está manteniendo
mucho más discreta si les está
facilitando acceso a internet etcétera
al menos supuestamente en teoría pero
está también la cuestión digamos de las
negociaciones nucleares entre Irán en
Estados Unidos en la Revolución árabe o
en la primavera árabe aquellas
negociaciones estaban avanzando ahora
mismo estas negociaciones están
completamente estancadas y además Irán
está apoyando a Rusia en la invasión de
Ucrania claro le está vendiendo algunos
drones Y eso generado toda una
controversia en la región de medio
oriente yo lo que veo acá es que veo a
los iraníes muy decididos a salir a las
calles a reclamar lo que ellos quieren
ahora para su país pero yo no veo al
régimen de los ayatolás al gobierno
iraní
debilitado como para que uno piense que
se va a dar allí una un cierre de un
capítulo y empiece a otro ustedes dos
que piensan por acá quién alza la mano
primero Rafael que está que habla Rango
coincido perfectamente o sea el
régimen Jamás había estado ante tanta
presión y los manifestantes han estado
moviendo Esto no es algo casual ya
llevamos todo este tiempo en esto y para
resaltarlo del Consejo de derechos
humanos de la ONU es muy importante que
eso suceda porque incluso no sé si
ustedes les ha pasado para cubrir
información de allá es muy complejo es
muy complejo esta semana cerraron un
diario allá local y y y dificulta el
acceso a la información y si es así para
nosotros Cómo serán esas cifras
oficiales Hay una ong que hablan de 400
muertos de número de heridos Pero eso no
es información verificada no sabemos si
es verdad puede ser mayor o puede ser
menor Entonces es muy importante esta
misión de verificación de ver qué es lo
que está pasando allá sobre todo por ese
desconocimiento esa falta de información
dificulta las tareas y además pues
vuelve El dilema de soberanía o
protección de Derechos Humanos O qué es
lo que está pasando allá que es otro
debate completamente distinto y son los
alcances que tiene estos organismos
internacionales que pues ya está
levantando la mano y ven la necesidad de
intervenir Sí para ver y verificar
cifras los medios de comunicación
estamos dependiendo de ongs iraníes o de
algunas ong internacionales que tienen
operación allí porque las cifras
oficiales se demoran o o no hay forma de
contrastarlas Pablo Andrea perspectiva
de este tema y sumando algo a lo que
mencionaba mi compañero es también ver
qué más de 40 periodistas han sido
asesinados los han matado Sencillamente
porque no hay una libertad de prensa y
yo pienso que eso es algo que se ha
extendido no solo en Irán sino a nivel
mundial porque hoy en día el tema de las
redes sociales el tema de la Nueva Era
permite que las cosas sucedan ya
entonces tú puedes ver aún manifestante
que sube un vídeo en Twitter y de una
vez ya sabes que algo está pasando y lo
único que debes hacer es empezar a
investigar si eso es cierto o no pero ya
se empieza a volver viral y ahí es muy
complicado Obviamente el hecho de
frenarlo entonces por eso tanta
represión obviamente contra la prensa
por ese lado pero retomando el tema que
tú decías ahorita también estoy de
acuerdo es en el hecho de que yo no creo
que sea el fin de los ayatos porque
finalmente es es Es un régimen que lleva
desde 1979 desde 79 cuando la Revolución
iraní y eso se posicionó en ese momento
y llevan años y años fortaleciéndose y
de hecho yo buscaba y es de manera
armamentística también no solo no solo
posicionándose como como los más
importantes en el en el ámbito religioso
sino también a un nivel que ha elevado
irán a otra proyección Entonces yo no
pienso que por unas protestas civiles
sea el fin de un régimen que lleva por
tantos años cuando las represiones
vienen sucediendo por tanto tiempo pero
que recordemos que lo que rebozó la copa
fue precisamente la muerte de esta chica
Aunque podría ser un primer paso o sea
todo todo se forja en la historia todo
puede ser pero tiene una ramificaciones
Pablo Ya aquí puede complementar si
quiere de una ramificaciones muy
importantes en el ámbito militar Como
dice Pablo Andrea las fuerzas cuts his
bola la ramificaciones en países como
Venezuela Incluso en Argentina ya
sabemos la controversia que hay por este
avión iraní venezolano que está retenido
en ezeiza en Buenos Aires que ya están
destapando allí También una una red de
transporte entre los dos países la
ramificaciones de Irán a nivel mundial
son importantes y eso puede que lo lo
ayuda a mantenerse fuerte Porque además
tiene como financiarse con venta de oro
con venta de petróleo y bueno también
está enriqueciendo uranio que eso le
preocupa también a la comunidad
internacional Pablo para el cierre
lo que has mencionado precisamente del
uranio es muy importante porque aquí
digamos el gobierno iraní esta semana ha
dado una señal muy clara de que ellos no
piensan dar marcha atrás al anunciar que
van a
refinar digamos una enriquecer uranio
hasta el 60%. están elevándolo todavía
les quedaría llegar hasta el 90 Pero
esto es muy significativo y además
también es muy significativo donde lo
están haciendo lo están haciendo en una
base militar la de fortdog que es muy
curioso porque es una base militar que
Estados Unidos en las negociaciones
durante el gobierno Obama cuando Estados
Unidos se Irán llegaron a un acuerdo
para congelar el programa nucleares de
Irán Estados Unidos intentó sin éxito
que esta base fuera cerrada y
precisamente quien negociaba Entonces
era Wendy Sherman que ahora mismo es la
número 2 del departamento de estado e
Irán siempre se negó a ello por qué
porque esta base es mucho más
invulnerable a todo tipo de ataques
incluyendo ciberataques que la de latams
que era la principal que Hasta ahora ha
tenido Irán con lo cual es un es un
salto cualitativo importante además
tenemos un nuevo Primer Ministro en
Israel y bienestar Yahoo que las se
caracteriza digamos por su tolerancia
hacia la idea de un Irán nuclear con lo
cual digamos que si es una Caldera es
una olla a presión la presión sigue
subiendo y esperemos que no estalle
obviamente esperemos que no estalle lo
que sí es cierto es que las
manifestaciones Tal parece que van a
seguir allí en las calles de la ciudad
de iraníes para el cierre dejó este
comentario que creo que hay que ponerle
lupa porque a lo mejor en los próximos
días vamos a estar comentandolo y es lo
que está pasando con La minoría kurda
que está haciendo
pues reprimida Por parte de las fuerzas
militares iraníes en las provincias del
cortistán iraní pero también en este
momento está recibiendo ataques por
parte de los turcos en el kurdistán
sirio en el norte del país vemos otra
vez a los kurdos acorralados por iraníes
por turcos y este pueblo pues
simplemente en la mitad allí en el fuego
cruzado vamos a ver qué pasa con ellos
para el cierre del programa para este
último bloque pues tenemos Tenemos que
hablar de fútbol obviamente es el evento
internacional deportivo del año ese
mundial de Qatar del 2022 y ha llamado
mucho la atención no solamente los
resultados que han estado completamente
nos ha dejado con la boca abierta Por
ejemplo el partido de Argentina o el de
Alemania pero las protestas de los
equipos de los jugadores de las
delegaciones toda esta controversia que
hay en los alemanes posando para la foto
oficial con la boca tapada la ciudadanía
es sin cantar el himno nacional de su
país por lo menos para el primer
encuentro para el segundo ya lo cantaron
toda la controversia que ha habido en
torno al equipo de Dinamarca que iban a
jugar con una camiseta negra que iban a
salir con una banda en el brazo que se
iban a retirar de la FIFA que ya no iban
a estar bueno Dinamarca dado para hablar
en los últimos días de todo tipo de
temas como ven ustedes este mundial
primero les pregunto sigan el mundial
comienzo por acá por los invitados en el
estudio Pablo Andrea tengo que ser muy
franca Yo sigo el mundial pero creo que
por mi esposo lo sigo aún más porque no
se pierde ni un solo partido entonces
dice como madrugo a la hora que sea con
tal de poder ver cada cada partido Y
aprovechar el momento pero
bueno me pregunta si sigo el mundial sí
lo sigo y obviamente lo he analizado a
fondo con todo el tema político que se
ha visto ahí entre líneas también y
obviamente por por por equipos como
Dinamarca
Irán en Alemania y y tantas tantos
espacios que han aprovechado
precisamente para poder generar como
esas protestas o alzar una voz por
decirlo de esa manera a favor de su país
entonces nomás ahorita mencionabas el
tema de Dinamarca con el con la camiseta
que quería tener un lema como a favor de
los Derechos Humanos finalmente no se
pudo tener porque la FIFA bueno tiene
sus establecimientos sus reglas y no no
se puede proyectar algo en el uniforme
pero es una manera de ellos de poder
hablar y también me acuerdo Algo súper
importante creo para mí es importante y
es que kairos por parte Irán también
habló hizo un comentario cuando le
hicieron la pregunta de Usted qué opina
con lo que está pasando en las con las
manifestaciones en Irán y él dice cuánto
te están pagando cuánto le preguntó al
periodista porque de pronto se está
tomando el hecho de que sea un mundial
de fútbol y se está tomando es Para
aprovechar y sacar información política
claro Entonces ahí es como es es un
dilema y por eso iniciando cuando
preguntados Cómo ha terminado la semana
y que acá mi compañero también decía ha
sido muy contradictoria porque es en
medio de la emoción pero también en
medio de una atención política a nivel
mundial muy fuerte vamos a ver partidos
goles y terminamos en debates después de
un partido
donde están reunidos representantes de
los países oficiales ganadores de
política pero el tema termina saliendo y
también es parte una estrategia porque
todo el mundo tiene los ojos puestos en
este momento en Qatar todo el mundo está
siguiendo esto y estos mensajes que
incluso los que no han salido terminan
siendo más simbólicos que los que
hubieran salido Entonces es llamar la
atención y también levantar la mano y
decir Oiga está pasando esto estamos acá
pero mire lo que nos está pasando y es
también una oportunidad
diríamos de dar pantalla de que entienda
lo que está pasando y no es y no
desligar eso Entonces eso simplemente
valioso todo el mundo lo está viendo
para responder a tu pregunta en las
salas de reacción tenemos un televisor
prendido todo el tiempo con En qué
partido van y todo el mundo está
trabajando y levanta la cabeza cuando
escucha Y le suben el volumen y todos
estamos ahí conectados y es un tema que
no se puede desligar finalmente esas
personas van allá un tiempo pero se van
a regresar a sus países tienen familia
allá tienen problemas allá entonces
ya otro dilema es el que ha pasado por
ejemplo con los cantantes que varias
preguntan Y de pronto sí y se retiraron
cada uno verá como aborda el tema de
cada uno verá Cómo se acerca a sus
realidades Y cómo también a su mesa
representación que de pronto puede tener
Y pues si ellos son figuras de sus
países están en toda la libertad de
hacerlo ya que les permitan o no es es
otro dilema y es otro punto que se ha
puesto en la agenda pero si es una
ventana para mostrar realidades Pablo su
opinión
sí Bueno yo lo primero de todo tengo que
reconocer que que yo soy O sea mi
ignorancia en materia de fútbol es
enciclopédica
tranquilo igual absolutamente nada del
mundial ayer aquí en Washington vigente
con los colores de Brasil por la calle y
dije Ah pues hoy debe de jugar Brasil es
todo lo que es todo lo que sea y luego
en grupos de WhatsApp sin mis amigos
comentan pero vamos esto lo que sé pero
bueno centrándonos en el en el partido
político digamos en Qatar yo creo que
esto es en parte esto es inevitable o
sea el fútbol es ahora mismo el deporte
del mundo es el deporte de todo el
planeta tierra y la FIFA ha hecho un
trabajo además Muy bueno muy eficaz a la
hora de extender el fútbol a todo el
mundo con la sección de Estados Unidos
el fútbol es prácticamente el deporte
universal con lo cual también Es lógico
que los jugadores de fútbol que además
en muchos casos son verdaderos iconos
culturales
iconos sociales además de millonarios
pues llevan a cabo digamos
manifestaciones o pronunciamientos
políticos la gran paradoja mi opinión es
que está teniendo lugar en Qatar que es
fundamentalmente el país que ha
inventado a los talibán Y esto no se
está no está saliendo por ningún sitio
es decir la versión original de los
alemán fue inventada por Arabia saudí o
se emiratos y Pakistán la versión actual
de los talibán fermentada por Pakistán y
Qatar de hecho el Qatar los talibán
tienen una representación cuasi
diplomática y fue la sede fue la sede de
diálogo con Estados Unidos también
Exactamente La gran paradoja es que en
Qatar Estados Unidos también tiene una
base militar de las más importantes que
tiene en la región
con lo cual yo creo que se abren muchas
cuestiones no en este sentido estamos
hablando de Irán pero no estamos
hablando por ejemplo de Afganistán ahora
Estamos hablando de Qatar donde al
parecer 6.500 personas todas ellas
extranjeros murieron construyendo
estadios en los que se celebra el
mundial
sí tema que también hemos tratado en
este programa lo tratamos justamente en
días previos a la inauguración del
mundial me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa quiero
preguntarles a Qué temas le van a estar
poniendo la lupa la próxima semana en
sus relaciones en sus reportajes en sus
investigaciones comienzo con Pablo en
Washington muy puntual por favor
Ucrania
y energía y petróleo puntos importantes
por este lado Pablo Andrea diálogos
oposición Venezuela gobierno de
Venezuela eln Colombia y también
Obviamente el mundial todo lo que siga
sucedió Yo creo que es para toda las
reacciones pero finalmente estar con el
foco puesto en que va a empezar a
suceder y que puede pasar pues a partir
de cada partido Rafael para el cierre
muy importante más de 600 tiroteos este
año en Estados Unidos ya los noticieros
están abriendo el noticiero más reputado
de Estados Unidos habría esta semana
diciendo seguimos en el mismo punto no
es así podríamos ser cualquiera de
nosotros Claro Entonces es un tema que
se ha venido escalando y hay un problema
es que se convierta en parte de la
cotidianidad qué tal parece que eso lo
que está pasando porque no hay ningún
tipo de cambios en torno a ese tema no
hay legislación no hay protestas por
parte de los ciudadanos los reclamos se
están como minimizando a lo largo de
ancho de Estados Unidos Pues yo a Pablo
a Rafael y a Pablo Andrea agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros en
el programa de hoy es todo por esta
semana Recuerden que pueden seguir
sintonizando la programación de France
24 la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Pedro Ruiz y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Lina Guzmán
y de Laura Espinosa Pueden seguir en
sintonía France 24 dejen sus comentarios
a través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]